what is happening reject nation it's
Greg al Bhatia and it's John here so
with the week of Comicon upon us
Southern from comic-con has not dropped
jigsaw sure a little boy now John and I
are pretty interested in I know John's
really excited for the off fan I'm I'm
seeing all the Saw movies so I'm
definitely intrigued by it especially
after hearing that quote that the spirit
brother mother doubt without talking
about what they want to do totally
different with this film more fun less
vicious yeah still the stuff you love
but let's see if the trailer conveys any
of the new approach that they were
talking about yeah
so will this be another dark unit yeah
every time I see you dicks on the bike
Billy I was thinking this sketch now
your mouth is covered in something that
it will be a little sooner like what
okay
if you'll have to download the funniest
saw a caduceus best ones are
[Music]
an application on the victims because of
these veggies oh he's been dead two days
this is all the body the truth will set
you free
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
hell yeah
[Music]
little time with you
[Music]
supplied under the fingernails of our
victims John Kramer jigsaw killer
[Music]
oh oh no it's not creepy
oh hell yeah
Helly I'm happy to do a saw trailer that
looks like that oh man it actually looks
like it's having fun yeah yeah I know
we've been invited up the reaction to
reviews Viper because the Comic Con week
we're going to keep the reactions
reviews you'll notice part of the save
me what amigos but from what the spirit
brothers were saying about this it
really is conveyed in this trailer and
it looks like they're having way more
fun with it not just because of the
choice of music that it chose to overlay
over the images that you see in this
trailer where you can see just by even
the setups the way how things are shot
like when they're set in that like sand
traveling just everything starts falling
in front of them it's a little bit silly
that there's going to be a little bit
more banter here between the people who
are set up in these traps I think here
with what they were saying it doesn't
look like it's probably going to be as
violent or just go tack I'm sure it will
so have stuff like it I'm sure it'll
have gore I'm sure it'll have like crazy
traps but yeah I think I think the way
he put it is that this doesn't look as
vicious as the oh yeah doesn't look at
like one it looks shot very different to
the other ones were shot kind of this
grimy dark look to it here that it seems
more composed it's framed differently
then the lighting looks different too
it's shot like a like a real film I cut
a little budget or thriller yeah boobies
kind of have a vibe like that this feels
like a like a much bigger type of
production even though it might not be
it feels like the filmmakers are more on
the level of what you know how James
wants or at all and that wasn't it was
just a low-budget movie and now it's the
eighth film on the franchise I got the
spirit brothers doing this and you could
feel the touch behind the camera here
yeah definitely and I like the fact that
they started off this trailer with
actually kind of genuinely creepy moment
with that reveal the person hanging out
that bridge shot like a horror movie
yeah yeah and then
Jonah's into the more fun so I mean this
trailers is kind of a series of images
so I don't know how this is going to
work out I'm wondering where all these
different locations are and how they fit
together but at least as a soft fan what
this communicated to me is this is going
to have kind of everything you know and
love about saw but it may be a more
broad so ya know it's got cop drama
investigations enough it's got a lot of
different people in this game I can't
tell if they're all the same or if we're
going to see a bunch of different kinds
of games but seems like you got like
five people sort of doing this thing so
yeah it's got a little bit of everything
I remember about saw and some new flares
and that gets me excited for this for
sure like I hope they knew and after saw
three it has the other classic mystery
question is this guy still alive yeah we
did that for life for horror movies that
are definite again my heart and soul
solitary individual I was there's this
all the time as a person who likes these
movies but has sat through seven of them
I'm ready for a change I'm ready for
them to mix it up in this you just get
more grimy and nasty it not just in like
the violence but even like the tone and
the way it was shot I'm happy to see
that it's taking a more fun approach and
that makes it that makes me want to go
back to the theater and check out what I
would want to see this in the theater
sort of new person oh yeah yeah I think
that you would want to not watch in the
dark on a Saturday night at home yeah
you want to go out and kind of squirm
with it feels like the first time saw
could be a Halloween type of movie yeah
yeah cuz Halloween they inherently has
that kind of fun yeah and that some
things like Saw movies have always been
kind of you can watch them any time of
year for me they're not particularly an
Alabama SH so yeah I would be psyched if
this became the perfect soft for
Halloween time hell yeah yeah alright
guys well what do you think of the
jigsaw trailer are you excited to
revisit this the jigsaw world subscribe
to the reel rejects become a part of the
reject nation click that notification
bell he is - aw Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram and he's the social media
manager of Blum house without one or
over there please go check out our
exclusive perks and rewards over at
patreon.com slash the real rejects would
love to have you become a part of the
growing community over there having a
total blast of those folks come cuddle
with us